three trials are starting this week
jesse smilet
jizzlane maxwell
i still have not figured out how to
pronounce her first name where to go
with jizzling jizzline maxwell and kim
potter potter was the officer who
accidentally shot dante right in
minneapolis during a traffic stop she
was trying to arrest him he fought her
uh she meant to reach for her taser but
she pulled her gun instead just to give
you an idea of how this trial is being
covered and to kind of review some of
the facts of the case here's the local
nbc affiliate talking about and and this
is
talking about the case and specifically
dante wright's family
who had a press conference yesterday and
uh and what they're saying about this
we are expecting justice we are not
asking for it one day before jury
selection begins in the manslaughter
trial of kim potter dozens of community
leaders and families of those killed at
the hands of law enforcement stood in
solidarity with donte wright's mother
katie thank everybody for the support
back on april 11th wright a 20 year old
black man was pulled over by brooklyn
center police officers due to expired
tags officer kim potter pulled out her
gun and shot wright once in the chest as
seen in body camera footage potter later
said she meant to pull out her taser
instead of her gun potter now faces
first and second degree manslaughter
charges defense attorneys argue the
shooting was an accident dante wright
was a student of mine at edison high
school george floyd's girlfriend
courtney ross recalled the day she first
heard of wright's death by the time i
got home
i found out that that man
that young man
was dante wright
mind you
dante's murder took place
during the international trial
of my man george floyd
um okay so there's there's
the trial dante right what his family is
saying
and we get the picture
uh as always
the necessary picture of dante wright
you know sitting there holding a child
um
looking very very innocent
what we should remember is that dante
wright
the way the media reports it is that
dante wright was stopped for a traffic
violation
and then i think originally the story it
was some something it's always bogus
almost all the details you hear about
these high-profile police shootings
the the initial details are almost
always completely bogus not even based
on reality but but totally bogus so i
think originally we heard something
about
he was pulled over for an air freshener
so the original story was that he was
not only pulled over for it but but shot
and executed for having an air freshener
in his car that was the story that made
it made its uh and as we know the saying
you know the lie makes all the way
around the world before the truth can
get its pants on and so that was the lie
in that case while the truth is
struggling to get its pants on and get
out there the lie was that he was
executed in cold blood
for having a little uh you know little
christmas tree
air freshener hanging on his on his
windshield
on his rear view mirror that was not
true at all
he was pulled over for a traffic
violation but then it then they
discovered that he had an open
warrant for his arrest
and so that's why they tried to arrest
him not for a traffic violation
but because he had an open warrant for
his arrest
and that's what you do with someone when
they have an open warrant for their
arrest why did he have an open warrant
for his arrest well he had it in
connection
with an incident where he allegedly
pointed a gun at a woman
and robbed her attempted to rob her
he also choked her and uh according to
the victim stuck his hand down her shirt
looking for a wad of cash which is
sexual assault of course so he sexually
assaulted a woman pointed a gun at her
and tried to rob her
that's why
that's the crime that
that lays the bottom there of that of
that arrest warrant now is my
opportunity to tell you about uh this
product i'm really excited about you
know because anything anything with
sharp any kind of sharp i don't know why
they let me carry sharp objects around
and have them in studio they probably
won't after they see how i do this but
uh these are the cami koto knives which
is we get into the holiday season you're
gonna have people over you're cooking
meals and everything you want to be able
to impress them by waving knives around
their face no by uh by you know just
having these these knives in the kitchen
when you're doing all your cooking
camcorder taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan each kamikoto knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete because of their single bevel a
edge rather kamikoto knives can achieve
an unbelievably sharp edge you just
can't get with other knives it's one of
the reasons why when you're using these
knives they're great knives but you want
to practice safety you want to be very
safe when you're using these knives
chemical knives are used by several
chefs working at michelin star
restaurants so click the link below or
go to camikoto.com matt walsh and use
promo code matt walsh to save an extra
50
today
so what are they supposed to do
they pull someone over for a traffic
violation find out they have an arrest
warrant this is someone who's committed
armed robbery is the police are the
police supposed to say well hey uh
there's a warrant for you're an arrest
you're a dangerous person
but
you know we pulled you over for
something else so we're gonna let this
one slide okay
is that that what you think they should
do
well yeah that that's actually precisely
what the defunder police crowd would
prefer
they'd prefer to let let dante wright go
and victimize another woman
this continues that trend
that pattern
which is certainly not a coincidence
it goes far beyond a coincidence when
you have this pattern where
almost all of the martyrs for blm
especially in the last couple of years
not only are violent criminals but in
almost every case specifically they
target women
women are the targets of their of their
violence and that was the case for dante
wright
so that's why they tried to arrest him
he fought back
and they tried to tase him to bring him
in
and she she reached for the gun and shot
him instead
now we know that that happened we know
it was a mistake because she says on
camera she says basically says on camera
that it was a mistake and she didn't
mean to do
it legally
i don't know you know i don't like her
chances in court i think she's probably
going to go to jail
um so we'll see
but if it were up to me if i was on that
jury
would i send this woman to jail no i
would not
i wouldn't send her to jail
i look at this i put this in a similar
in a similar category to something like
a medical error you know a mistake that
that now there can be
medical errors that are made there can
be that are really malpractice
or a doctor or surgeon is being reckless
and if that happens then you have to
litigate it
but there are also hundreds of people or
more who die every year you know in
surgeries and that sort of thing from
medical errors that where nothing
reckless has happened it's just that
this is a life or death situation
life is hanging in the balance
and sometimes it can go the wrong way
and it's a terrible mistake but doesn't
mean you put someone in prison for it
so
the point is
when you are a wanted felon
an alleged armed robber
and the police are trying to bring you
in and they're trying to use peaceful
means to do it
and you start fighting them physically
if a mistake happens in the in the
process of that occurring where you are
physically fighting the cops
as a wanted person a violent felon
if a mistake happened an error happens i
put that on you
you could have avoided that easily
you deserve to go to jail that's what
should happen to you
you don't have a right to to resist and
and run away
you rob you pointed a gun at a woman and
robbed her
you need to face the music you need to
go to so you if you fight back because
you don't want to face up to what you
did
then you are taking your life into your
hands
you are putting yourself in a position
where really bad things can happen
like a mistake
and so i put it i put the onus on you
[Music]
um
that's how i would see it on a jury
that's what i would argue but i have no
confidence the confidence that the jury
here will argue the same
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated